good evening everyone and thank you
again brett and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm tammy bruce and tonight
joe biden's weakness and failure on the
world stage is as undeniable as ever
last night we discussed the smash and
grab looting of this country by the
democrats through their policies and
through legislation but that's not the
only front of destruction we're facing
the biden harris clown show is also
looting us of our reputation our
standing and our influence upon the
world because as american adversaries
like russia and china and intensify
their aggression the biden
administration is retreating to the same
political platitudes the same tired
washington tropes and the same tepid
responses to global threats staring us
right in the face earlier today joe
biden met virtually with russian
president vladimir putin and typically
instead of signs of decisive action from
our commander-in-chief to keep a hostile
actor in check what we're seeing from
the biden gang is a reflex to appease
our enemies while abandoning our allies
and ignoring the reality of how biden
set this dangerous table
the withdrawal from afghanistan which
was widely criticized how do you respond
to that criticism that president biden
is being too weak with history vladimir
putin
standing behind then president medvedev
in 2008
invaded georgia when we had 150 000 or
more troops deployed in iraq and
afghanistan
so the connection between our
deployments and foreign wars and the
calculus of russian leaders when it
comes to the post-soviet space there's
not good evidence to support that
what was even what did that mean it was
clearly a deflection from jake sullivan
the question was about the impact of our
embarrassing afghanistan retreat on our
national security not about troop levels
in the middle east so leave it to
sullivan to convin to continue spreading
uh lies about russia just like he did
five years ago when he was pushed when
he was pushing the steele dossier for
hillary clinton don't forget that and
the threats are showing no signs of
slowing down russia is well on their way
to a military buildup along the
ukrainian border it's so serious there
are now reports biden is telling
americans we'll evacuate them if need be
considering what happened in afghanistan
that sounds more like a threat than a
promise now we continue to see signs of
china's increasing aggression towards
taiwan in addition to reports of the
construction of a military base off of
africa's atlantic coast and to many
americans the mess in afghanistan
understandably still looms large
americans and our allies remain trapped
in that hellhole a story most legacy
media continues to ignore surrendering
to the taliban leaving in haste with
apparently little plan or strategy
abandoning our fellow americans they're
still in there you guys it's all
undermined confidence in america's
resolve and the world has noticed
when will the biden gang be honest about
their mistakes about their missteps and
about their lack of solutions only when
that happens can we get off our knees
because get this the administration
announced this week a diplomatic boycott
of the 2022 winter olympics in beijing
which are happening this february
meaning that no diplomatic officials or
official representatives will attend the
games but let's be honest does anyone
really care if secretary of state tony
blinken or some random undersecretary or
joe biden even for that matter doesn't
attend the olympics
even the chinese communist party says
it's a meaningless action and that no
one really cares when asked about the
decision jan saki said this
we will not be contributing to the
fanfare of the games u.s diplomatic or
official representation would treat
these games as business as usual in the
face of the prc's egregious human rights
abuses and atrocities in xinjiang
you know ask yourself what exactly is
this empty gesture supposed to
accomplish is this supposed to strike
fear into the heart of our enemies is
this supposed to help hold beijing
accountable for their ongoing human
rights abuses will it help stop chinese
theft of american intellectual property
or stop any of their malign behavior and
it's the same weakness from the
democratic establishment we see abroad
that's also present here at home
pandering to progressives on some of the
most extreme policy positions pandering
to those who want the most devastation
and the most control it's all now at the
center of the democrat playbook because
for whatever reason most moderate center
liberals that are still around are
bending the knee to it all of this is
fed by the same feckless weakness the
same lack of ideals principles and
vision resulting in empty actions bad
decisions constant lying in fact then to
cover up the charade the democratic
party more than ever is being driven by
miserable incompetent weaklings there's
no other way to put it unable to even
fully grasp the implications of their
own policies consider this after four
years of hysterical russia collusion
fear-mongering what's one of the first
things joe biden did when he got into
office he killed the pipelines here in
the united states and then cleared the
way for the nordstrom 2 pipeline that
will give putin even more control over
europe that alone was of course was a
signal to putin that the new american
president was incompetent and willing to
abandon his own country and europe to
the bloody russian bear and now here we
are with the by the administration
pleading with opec to drill more oil as
energy prices surge here at home now
biden is reduced to begging germany to
step in and cancel the controversial
pipeline if russia invades ukraine
all of this was predictable and
predicted the same corruption and rot
that has contributed to an inflation to
the supply chain crisis which continues
coveted response failures the crime
surge it's the same feckless idiocy that
is inspiring the bad guys around the
world and what's the biden team's
response to all of this actually
complaining that the press coverage is
just too darn negative
as white house chief of staff ron klain
is now trying to claim that the media
has been tougher on biden that they they
ever were on trump you know what exactly
what were you expecting ron maybe he
might be watching to receive glowing
coverage of the debacle in afghanistan
or fawning praise for surging prices or
endless puff pieces for biden breaking
nearly every one of his major campaign
promises in fact
ladies and gentlemen that was exactly
what ron klein was expecting and
directly indicts the condition of
america's legacy media and we are are we
really you have to ask expected to
believe that the same media that went
all out to smear trump you know 24 7 and
to protect joe biden during the entire
2020 campaign
you know accepting a a basement campaign
is suddenly too hard on poor old joe and
company yeah no not really not a chance
whatever critical coverage biden is
receiving is a result of his failures
being so undeniable and obvious that
there's not much else left to say and
get this we are now learning that the
white house is working behind the scenes
with news outlets
to find and get to get a more positive
coverage in an apparent effort to have
the press help them cover up for their
massive failures now they're not even
trying to hide the collusion it's
weakness like we've never seen and
frankly panic as well
rather than actually find solutions to
mounting crises the democrats solution
is to find new and creative ways to
reshape the coverage in their favor and
win the news cycle hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else